am 12 jänner fand im raiffeisen forum
der sicherheitspolitische jahresauftakt
für doch in 17 statt globale
sicherheitspolitik entwicklungen im
europäischen umfeld und auswirkungen auf
die sicherheit österreichs migration
terrorismus und bedrohung waren die
themen bundesminister ad school dann ist
schon richtig dass sich das
österreichische bundesheer diesen drei
verschiedene diesen drei bereichen
gehörig weiterentwickeln muss in den
bereich seiner thematik ich finde in den
bereich terrorismus habe auch in der
migrationsfrage glaube es wird ein nicht
nur für die verteidigung sondern
generell ein sehr spannendes jahr für
deine herausforderndes jahr
und ich glaube das wichtigste für uns
alle nicht nur für den moment zu handeln
sondern wirklich auch perspektivisch vor
zu denken um schon einen schritt weiter
zu sein wie andere geben